most people think of hunger as a
scarcity problem but it's not it's a
logistics problem there's more than
enough high-quality food to go around
we're not recovering hot dogs and pizza
crusts and popcorn we're having pulled
pork sandwiches and lobster rolls and
$300 cheese's food should be given with
dignity regardless of who you are
and that also means giving the highest
quality of food to those who are in need
because it is food that is a stepping
stone for everything whether it's health
education job security
programs like this what it does it
allows our guests to be able to be in a
position to not have to worry about
being fat when we get food donations
they can focus on finding housing
employment that way they can leave
homelessness behind hobbies like hunger
shouldn't exist because it's not a lack
of food
it's an inequitable and inefficient
distribution of it